alors c'est très simple c'est jean
michel maire guy bajoit béton va faire
le tour du quartier jean michel bernat
essayer d'accumuler le plus de points
possibles avec des épreuves les chères
et des preuves de chant des épreuves de
musique et vous allez jouer avec nous je
vous le dis c'est tiré d'un format qui
s'appelle singing in the car voilà qui
était dans notre propre société de
production et on a fait ça fait très
longtemps qu'on va là on prépare sa et
jean michel et le premier parce que
c'est son anniversaire la stationnement
laisser parties déchirées besoin avec
nous à chaque babacar on y va les habits
déchirés de jouer avec nous à ce stade
baba cas on y va d'abord on va t'en vas
chanter un peu en cannabis est alors ça
peut coupler tu donnes ça quand michel
jean michel on va faire une première
étoile est ce que tu faisais aussi
solliciter ces barques et la première ex
alors c'est le baba au kit évoqué ses
meetings la montagne et ouais voire
chantée par dessus des paroles et à un
moment la musique s'arrête de son
s'arrête je suis toujours dans le rythme
si je suis donc chez les pros vingt deux
points par par moment je suis toujours
me répond d'accord le premier blindés
propres à ces musiques à trompe ou
presque aux coups et aux cadenas
derrière merci les chéris musique4 où
c'est parti on va jouer avec on va
s'aimer c'est gilbert montagné c'est
parti on va s'aimer on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
a touché le ciel se séparer un léger
grove est sombre tout mais comme les
hirondelles pour assumer a tellement tu
les belles on va jeter les clés de la
maison on va arriver à d'autres c'est
qu'on va quitter les murs de prison
s'est pas raté pas mal on va s'aimer sur
une étoile ou sur un oreiller au fond
d'un train ou dans un grenier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va s'aimer
dans un avion sur le pont d'un bateau on
va s'aimer à se brûler la peau à son
volet toujours tout fait pour l'amour
[Musique]
pourquoi
père noël il a trouvé un point à la fin
quoi c'est gagné 5,5 trois mâles 5 fois
pour jour les chaumières on va passer à
la deuxième épreuve jean michel devynck
lâche on passe à la deuxième épreuve de
la bac lâche alors c'est quoi sur la
chanson préférée que vladimir ilitch de
michel sardou ma famille me balader
pendant la chanson raymond baillou peut
commencer à sésame elle qui vient de me
perturber
il faut que j'arrive à continuer à
rester concentré à coup tu n'as chantier
quoi qu'il arrive
merci tout à tuer c'est très bien des
règles du jeu la coquille au les biens
volés par esi sur l'incroyable la partie
pour l'impact attention il ya un bus les
chéris quand même devant
merci merci merci attention c'est la
seule moto en fait au lieu de nous au
lieu d'être bien il dit plus si nous
tanne a annoncé une enveloppe et nous
bloque merci à l'ailé chéri attention
alors dont elle va te perturbée elle va
me rassurer sur bardi reste que tu m'as
tu dois toujours chanté vous chantez
avec jean michel c'est parti on y va on
y va
enfin tours ah oui sympa
[Musique]
sa personne
zéro point la niche
pas toi tu as aimé
merci
mouillart
robin que celle aux gens qu'on
emprisonne
[Musique]
aux confins du pays
[Rires]
ce qui m'a choqué trois quilles
[Musique]
tu voi e
mon cousin deux fois
[Musique]
et
alors asie là où bon franchement c'est
pas le père noël s'est passé je sais
faire dont l'on réserve était pas les
bonnes paroles zéro point voilà père
noël 0 point il est dur à l'an passé la
première fois la troisième épreuve alice
saint jo est expliqué c'est le mégalithe
il va avoir dix titres qui vont passer
il va falloir qu'il trouve le maximum
dans l'intervalle est possible sur un
accord à la fin où sa chanson ou de
champion d'interprètes d'accord vous
êtes prêt vous jouez avec nous également
chez vous hashtag babacar on voit
chanter on va kiffer dans personne
n'était donc ceux qui veulent aider pas
vous jouez la laponie parce que vous
allez le faire aussi les chéris
attention c'est parti
troisième épreuve ya des titres qui
suivent on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
loire pappano
geagea la la la
[Musique]
tapez pas cassé la boîte alors c'est bon
alors voilà qu amour 1 alors attendons
comme ça dit hatamura non non c'est pas
camorra déjà 0 me et ayane nakamura donc
ça n'est pas pu y avait qui johnny
johnny tu dis oui bien sûr jamais choisi
il y avait des crs
ouais il y avait bruel y avait quoi
bruel noël repas il y avait rapporté le
4 à watts on va ré écouter après
l'incendié de marché à l'élite à l'épée
dans la droit 1 1 à 3 non y'a plus qu'à
3 pouces et le ciel ne fait pas peur
bent amel bent soprano non non allez hop
attention on va ré écouter et on va voir
combien de points c'est parti marianne
mais mariah carey c'est vache et par
dessus tout elle est éternelle c'est bon
[Musique]
ça c'est qu'ils arrivent à mireille
mathieu qu'on adore mettre avec bientôt
attaquer badiate l'amour accueil à dacca
- là là là là c'est la jay leno
[Musique]
venus est chaud et ça me fait pas peur
même à taïwan tu la vois là alors on a
il à combien de points 9 mois on a neuf
points et l'a9 pente où jean-michel non
et on en a compté 5 père noël new island
a eu que quatre mais à noël m'a dit il à
le faire même si c'est dur serait le
père noël a dit cats est calme le père
denis lacombe impôts alors 9 points
merci père noël vous êtes vraiment bien
et massa au regard du duo mrm est bon je
sais je sais comme ça et il y avait
celle là on va rentrer au studio
[Musique]
jo
mais pas comment faire
[Musique]
alors il ya une tablette preuve une
dernière étape je dois sauter les
oignons des montants de diverses
c'est très simple je vais te mettre
mariah carey la chanson de mariah carey
dodo et tu vas devoir avec le meilleur
possible là dessus tu fais un show ce
sera noté sur dix points par le père
noël derrière attend noël
attention vous chantez également c'est
vous c'est chaud c'est cela qui fait
cette chanson noël c'est parti je me
donne tout c'est parti
mais sur la base de coûts j'ai dit
qu'aux différentes et chaque santé
bon
[Musique]
ce rattrapage est pour ce produit
je ferai ce que tu voudras
[Musique]
on en peut mieux sais pas vous mais nous
on roule au père noël combattu lui met
alors à mon avis avant tient qu'aux nu
c'est rythme ouais donc on voit quand
même sympa je veux type s'ils sont
distants père noël tu peux pas faire ça
mais comme à qui va mettre aux autres
fâché car noël je peux et alors le
défaut de sardou autant dire que je
l'aimé tu mets 6 sur 10 un niveau bas
c'est le père noël qui décide c'est
l'homme veut pas trop donc ce qui nous
fait en tout pour jean michel maire 11
15 je fais c'est ce que 9 et 6 cas le
pack jeu et mon fils si la calabre un
jour après que celui qui aura le plus de
points à la fin de la semaine sera
qualité pour la laponie
regardez les chéris au rodéo studio
voilà après
ça passe ça passe ou pas bien sûr noté
howard maintient ses bouquets des
champions va rigoler jean-michel donc
jean-michel à 15 points
casser tous les mecs n'hésitez pas on
adore
[Rires]